Welcome back.
Well, we're now on problem
number 11.
And this says the circle above
has center o, and diameter ab.
And it's a dotted line in the
book, but I made it a solid
green line.
The two semi-circles have
diameters oa, so this is one
semi-circle and this is
its diameter, oa.
And then ob, this is the
other semi-circle.
It's ob.
If the circumference of
the circle is 36 pi.
So, circumference of the circle,
of the big circle--
and actually I'll do it in
yellow, which is the color of
kind of the perimeter or the
circumference of that circle.
So they're saying the
circumference is 36 pi.
What is the length of the curved
path from ab to o?
So they want to figure out the
length of, essentially, this
brown path.
And so before we break into
the math, just how can we
think about this?
Well we have a big circle and
we know its circumference.
So if we know its circumference
we could figure
out its radius or its
diameter, right?
Because you know the formula,
circumference is
equal to 2 pi r.
So if we know the circumference
of this big
circle, we can actually
figure out its radius
by using this formula.
And the radius of the big
circle, which would be-- let's
say, oa or ob-- they're both
radiuses of the big circle--
than those are the diameter of
each of these half circles or
each of these semi-circles.
So if we know this diameter we
could take half of it and
re-use this formula, or say the
circumference is pi times
the diameter.
We could do either one.
And we could figure out-- let's
say we know this radius,
so we could figure out this.
Then we could figure out
the circumference
of this larger circle.
And I'll actually make the claim
that the circumference
of this larger circle is the
same as the circumference of
this half circle plus
this half circle.
And I think you know why.
If you just shifted this up then
you would get the other
half of this circle.
The other way you could have
done it is, you figure out the
circumference of this circle,
divide by 2 to get this.
Take the circumference of this
circle, divide by 2 to get
this and then add them.
But you'll get the same thing
as just the circumference of
this circle.
So let's do the problem.
So circumference is
equal to 2 pi r.
We know the circumference of
the larger circle is 36 pi.
So let's see, 36 pi is
equal to 2 pi r.
Divide both sides by 2 pi, and
I'll switch the sides too.
So you get r is equal to 36 pi
over 2 pi-- I just divided
both sides by 2 pi.
pi's cancel out.
36 divided by 2 is
equal to 18.
And so what's 18?
18 is this length right here.
Is this length.
We just figured out,
that's the radius
of the larger circle.
And now we could use this, which
is the diameter of the
smaller circle to figure out
its circumference using the
same formula.
And now I'm going to use brown
for this circumference.
So circumference is
equal to 2 pi r.
And that's the same thing as--
because 2 times the radius is
the diameter.
So that equals pi times
We know what the diameter
is, the diameter is 18.
So we could say circumference
is equal to
pi times the diameter.
The diameter is 18.
Or if we rearrange that
that's 18 pi.
And we're done.
Because what we just figured
out is the circumference of
this larger circle.
We could divide it by 2 and
figure out-- we could say that
this is 9 pi right here.
Just this piece.
This piece is 9 pi.
And if we do the same math here
on this piece, you would
also get 9 pi.
But that also adds
up to 18 pi.
Hopefully you understand
what I'm saying.
Let's move on to the
next problem.
So in the table above-- this is
our classic f of x table.
When x is 0, f of x is a.
When x is 1, f of x is 24.
When x is 2, f of x is b.
It says the table above shows
some values of the functions
of f. f is a linear function.
So what does a linear
function mean?
Linear means it's a line.
And that also means that
the slope is constant.
If you haven't gottem-- well,
if you haven't got past
algebra I, you probably haven't
seen functions with
non-constant slopes.
But like, for example,
quadratics don't
have constant slopes.
The linear means that the
slope is constant.
That's the one conclusion you
can make from that statement.
And then they want to know, what
is the value of a plus b?
a plus b is what?
So the only thing we know is
this table and we know that
it's linear.
And linear means that the
slope is constant.
So the slope is constant.
So let's see what we can
figure out the slope.
So that means the slope from x
is equal to 0 to x is equal to
1 is the same as the slope from
x is equal to 1, to x is
equal to 2.
So what's the slope if we
use these two terms?
Slope is change in-- well change
in f of x over change
in x, right?
So change in-- I mean it's
change in y over
change in x, right?
We could call this y instead.
So change in y-- let's see, 24
minus a-- and you might want
to review the slope video
if you forgot this.
24 minus a over the change
in x is 1 minus 0.
Well that's just 1.
So that equals 24
minus a, right?
And what's the slope
from these points?
Because we know it's constant.
We know the slope between these
two points is going to
be the same as the slope between
these two points.
Well, we do the same thing.
We take the end points' change
in y, so it's b minus 24 over
change in x, 2 minus 1.
So that equals-- well that's
just 1, so that
equals b minus 24.
So this is the slope between
these second two points, and
this the slope between
the first two points.
And since we know it's linear,
since we know this is a linear
equation, we can say well they
must be equal to each other.
So let's see if that gets us
to where we want to go.
So we know that 24 minus a
is equal to b minus 24.
Let's add 24 to both sides.
You get 48 minus a
is equal to b.
I just added 24 to both sides.
And if we add a to both sides,
I see the end point-- 48 is
equal to a plus b.
And that is choice C.
Let us move on.
And remember, all we did is we
used this information, and we
used the fact that slope
is constant.
So the only thing that you would
have had to know ahead
of time is the equation of the
slope, and that's change in y
over change in x, and that
linear means constant slope.
So they write a little
sequence up here,
this is number 13.
It's 3, 5, negative 5.
They say the first term in the
sequence of the numbers shown
is 3-- that's obvious.
They show that.
Each even number term is 2 more
than the previous term,
so we go from 3 to 5, that was
2 more, because this is the
second term, so it's an
even number term.
So this is 2 more.
And each odd number of term
after the first is minus 1
times the previous.
So minus 1 times this
term is minus 5.
So that's what they're saying.
For example, the second term
is 3 plus 2, and the third
term is minus 1 times 5.
What is the 55th term
of the sequence?
So on the SAT, whenever they ask
you some crazy term, like
the 100th term or the 55th term,
that a huge signal that
this sequence is probably going
to repeat itself and you
just have to figure
out the pattern.
And then once you know that
pattern I'll show you how to
figure out the 500th term
if you have to.
So with any sequence the best
thing to do is just write out
a bunch of terms. So we start
at 3, we add 2, we get 5.
We multiply that
by negative 1.
This is plus 2.
So we multiply by negative
1, times negative 1,
we get minus 5.
Then we want to add 2.
So 2 times negative 5 is--
we're adding 2, right.
2 plus negative 5 is minus 3.
I think I'm already seeing
a pattern here.
And then we have to multiply
that times minus
1 times minus 1.
That's not x minus 1, this
is times minus 1.
So minus 1 times 3.
So minus 1 times 3-- I should
do minus 1 time instead.
Minus 1 times 3,
well that's 3.
And then we add 2 to it,
plus 2, we get 5.
And it's interesting, then it's
going to start repeating.
Minus 1 is minus 5.
So let's see what the repetition
looks like.
The first term is 3, the second
term is 5, the third
term is minus 5, the fourth
term is minus 3.
The fifth term is 3 again.
The sixth term is
5, 7 and so on.
I'm almost out of time.
I'll continue this in
the next video.